does your process change every time you
write a screenplay or has it
evolved or sometimes you'll do it one
way and you'll plot and you'll
outline and other times you'll start
another way great question
and i know everyone has a different
process about when you're
developing a script or an idea for me
i feel like i've gotten that old adage
of
you know work smarter not harder
i think that ultimately boils down to
knowing to having a really solid
the first process is getting the log
line down where you have that
the log line and you have that hint of
irony it's it's um
you know um just you know
boiling it down to a sentence that you
can pitch to somebody like
what's it about and you know people get
it right away
um from there once i think you have that
locked in
then it's a matter of really breaking it
out into um
you know the main components of the
story and the structure for me that
is where i've really become a lot more
um
fastidious with my process of you know
knowing
like again what's the hard turn what's
the you know what's that inciting
incident
how does it affect the character what's
sending them off to that to that first
act turn
turning point then from there to the bin
point
and then intact three and how they're
changing along the way
um i think it was you know i was i'm
sure like
every writer you know obviously read the
blake snyder
you know save the cat and i think
honestly that's
that's probably the most uh
comprehensive book on screenwriting i i
would i recommend that anyone who's
looking to break in i always tell them
to get
you know save the cat save the cat goes
to the movies
because i think blake snyder was really
on to something
so i really do follow i believe it's the
16 major beats that
he laid out in there and and you know
their purpose
and for me that really i think
you know i was going in that direction
before
i read the blake snyder novel but
certainly after and
and and he was also such an inspiring
writer um
uh blake snyder was but getting a good
idea
of you know how to you know really lay
out the story and how to structure it
that to me is is again is the most
important part of the process
you know i think once you have your log
line and your structure you know
you know the writing it's probably about
60 70 percent of the process i think the
actual writing is about 30 percent
you know because if you everything lined
up you know where your character is
going you know their journey
um it's going to make things a lot
easier for you
and of course things will always change
and you have to be open and flexible i
know some people who write
30 page outlines 40 page outlines i
usually try to keep it between six and
eight pages
um just because i feel like if you're
with an outline like that you sort of
lose some of the momentum the creativity
where if you have a good idea and you
you really have a good structure in
place knowing you know what
what scene comes after what scene comes
after what's seen and it's this
you know um snowball that keeps rolling
up
um you know if you keep it tight in
those first
in that outline and then from there you
can use that and then just transfer it
to
uh the final final draft or the actual
script
you know i think then you have good
momentum um
to keep to keep the flow the creative
flow going for sure and giving leaving
yourself room for some flexibility
because things will always come up
and um certainly has in anything that
i've ever written
and how long did you work on the log
line for take back
um the log line um that one actually
came
fairly quickly i don't
recall because it's been some time but i
think once
i think after really sort of attending
that particular church service
it it came pretty quickly and you know
again i pitched it to my manager at the
time and gave him a very like
you know bare-bones idea where i wanted
the story to go and he said yeah go for
it
you know he was always my he still is my
barometer and um
of you know we still throw ideas off
you know uh the wall at each other and
and i think it he definitely was
instrumental in you know giving me um uh
you know a good um sort of uh
good feedback on the log line and then
where the story was going to go
do you remember the exact log line the
exact
right um well i remember the i remember
the quick elevator pitch was always
going to be taken
it was going to be taken meets a history
of violence i i always loved
a history of violence for um i just
thought it was a
it was based on a graphic novel but i
loved you know the idea of this guy
who is you know he's he's living this
very
seemingly quiet life in the middle of
america
and he commits this act of heroism and
then
his past comes back to get him and we're
still not sure is it really him
and then you know we i i don't know if
anyone has seen it i want to spoil the
movie
but it really was for me i i basically
saw it as a
to be as simplistic as possible a female
version of a history of violence
um so it was i i guess at the time again
this is going back a few years the
original log line would have been
something like you know
you know a young woman living a
seemingly you know
uh happy existence in the small town
commits commits
act of heroism that brings evil forces
from her
her past life if you will will you ever
write a screenplay without outlining
first
no um
i know and
you know again my process is i have my
process
you know it's um a lot of people
have their way of doing things some
people can just i've known writers
who've been successful who are just able
to
they have it in their head and they're
just able to you know put it down on
paper
write go right to final draft and put it
on paper
now for me i have to be again i really
have to know how those beats turn
those the main beats turn in a story
and really what my character's journey
is and where they start and where they
end
and you know i know it seems pretty uh
rudimentary
but it's it's really for me yeah i don't
i don't think i could ever do that i
would be lost
you know um you know there's uh
as i'm sure a lot of your viewers know
you've you've heard of second act hell
where you you know you could write a
great first act
but then just get your character gets
completely lost in the second act and
that that morass that
when you haven't been when you haven't
plotted out and this again this just
applies to me
you know um knowing really where
where they're supposed to go you have to
be their their guide you have to be the
character's guide
um and if you don't know if you don't
have
again like some kind of blueprint and
play blue blueprint in place
you know it's not going to again this is
in my opinion
it it doesn't it doesn't help me um
again there's
there's as i said earlier there's i
always find you can
i try to be as flexible as possible the
story especially after you've written it
and you get feedback from
you know colleagues you know and others
um
you know and sometimes a script may just
not work and
you may write it and you think you know
this isn't
this isn't cutting it i have to go back
and you know
um reexamine and and maybe rip it apart
and try it again um and sometimes you
just have to move on it may just not be
the right time you may get inspired by
another idea
um but yeah the the
i would never i would never not outline
um
any kind of writing i do i always have
to have
a blueprint in place is discipline and
order something that you actually enjoy
yes
you know i try to write anywhere between
four and six hours a day
i think after sometimes longer it
depends i can go
you know eight to ten hours um before i
start
i think six hours is pretty much where
is my average where i can just you know
i can go to before i start you know i'm
like i think my brain is
need to just throw in the towel for the
day but yes no i'm usually up pretty
early
um you know usually writing i'd say
anywhere between
seven and eight you know and then i'll
work to the late morning
uh take a breath break do a little
exercise um
you know have breakfast and then work
again until the early evening
that's generally my structure um and
you know about it by that for a while
i know you talked about martial arts and
that's something that's part of your
life
yeah i know martial arts is a big part
of my life and um
i've been do i've been training for you
know over 10 years and
you know this sort of ties into you know
everyone's process is different you know
it was always this um
[Music]
not so much in our community but in in
other
i've heard of other you know people who
train in martial arts saying
you know one might be better than the
other and you know if you're doing if
you're doing some martial art
it's great because i feel like they're
so wonderful for the mental physical and
spiritual side of someone
to help them
you know as it is with writing everyone
has their own process and
you know whatever it might be whatever
it might
however you do something or however you
feel is
and if that works for you then god bless
um but um but yeah and again as far as
martial arts yes i think martial arts is
wonderful for discipline
for self-esteem um and
you know you're also you know
really i think tapping into similar
emotions sometimes as you are with
writing
you know there's there is definitely a
um
a spiritual side i think to um to
martial arts and
i think as it is with writing you know
you're getting in touch with certain
emotions
uh in a spiritual sense creative sense
um
and um if that makes any that makes any
sense
um but yeah i i feel that in a lot of
ways they
you know they run um and there's a
parallel
to both of them for sure one helps the
other
right speaking of spiritual i think the
writer of the exorcist and forgive me
i'm blanking on his name and i enjoy
was it william peter blotti yes i think
so i bought it right
and he said there's a rhythm or was that
the writer of straws
i don't know i read i read the exorcist
and i read jaws you know
the books i think it was william peter
blotti who wrote the exorcist i
i thought so yeah and he said and and he
was a very spiritual man and he said
that that there was a good writing has a
rhythm
yeah and i was wondering if if there's
almost a correlation between that and
then the martial arts because you're
you're getting into some sort of a flow
absolutely
um you know for me you know aside from
the joy that i get from my wife and my
uh
my daughter and my step children there
are um
and family and uh
when new york sports teams are actually
good
um there's a there's a there's
definitely
a um a high i get from
from writing um when you're investing a
character and you're really pushing
their story and you're locked in and
you're your character almost is speaking
for you
um and i've i've heard a lot of other
writers talk about that and i think
early in my career i'm like
you know what what are you talking about
but i think after you've done it for a
while and you
again have a good sense of where again
you have a good structure in place and
you know where your story is going
the characters in a sense will start
talking for you you know what you know
where
they they know you stop leading them and
they start leading you in a way
which is which is pretty neat and i
think that is what
for me what we hope to achieve and
martial arts absolutely
there are breakthroughs when you're in
tongsudo which is my martial art we have
um
we do we perform youngs which are
essentially you know improvised fighting
forms
um and there's something to be said when
you really
reach that um level when you're really
connected with your mind body and spirit
are all connected it's it's again it's
that
that just that rush of euphoria that you
really
and and it is a blend of creativity and
it's a blend of discipline it's a
it's a blend of focus that all comes
together
and it's it's you you really derive a
triumphant feeling from it
there's no doubt and uh you know
it's i know that you know
again if i if i leave the office and i'm
i'm really thrilled with something i
wrote i
i have a bounce in my step similar
martial arts if i really feel like i
gotta form down well
and then of course are the days where
you're like uh you know
i didn't have i wasn't really on it you
know and i'm i'm one to beat myself up
although i've gotten better thanks to
martial arts about not beating myself as
up as much as i used to
but there's definitely there there's
definitely links sure
and again in my opinion between the two
and i've been doing both for a long time
we were joking off camera while setting
up that you don't have to be the writer
that has like several scotches and his
chances you know you can be the
discipline writer that's like you said
up
yeah at five and having whatever chai or
yeah no it's funny yeah that story i was
yeah it was um that story derived from a
fact that my
you know my late dad um you know he
uh it was actually we were having a
discussion shortly before he passed away
um uh he was uh
i told him that i was going out with
some friends too
you know we were gonna have some scotch
and smoke some cigars which was a
mistake because
my dad you know my dad said
he said oh god he said i could just see
you in your apartment there writing
you know with a bottle of scotch and and
you know cigar going all night
and you know and that to me that's i'm
not a big drinker i
rarely smoke cigars but uh yeah that's
sort of the
um you know i guess almost like a parody
of writers from the
you know that or or stigma of writers
maybe that still exists like my dad was
probably old-fashioned in some ways
uh but those writers from the that that
uh bygone era of the
the golden era film as they said 30s 40s
50s you know up in their little uh
you know um uh i guess what were they um
bungalows uh you know writing until all
odd hours of the night you know
drinking scotch smoking cigarettes or
cigars but no i
you know my my process is you know two
cups of coffee and uh you know
through the day and i'm good no alcohol
infusion
or cigarettes or cigars so yeah yeah
you